So we were looking at the how do
we model the data.
So that is our question.
So in fact, what we have seen is
that there is a data and we need
to find the patterns and there
can be various types of
patterns.
We have seen the pattern for the
classification and clustering
association and normally et
cetera.
And we have seen that those
patterns are possible when we
understand the data and we model
the relations within the data
and then we will be able to, uh,
find the patterns and then
measure the quality of the
patterns and so on.
Now the question is that first
thing that we need to do is that
we need to have an understanding
of the data.
So so is it always an easy job?
So we were looking at the
factors like the data science
has an element of art and and it
also has the has the constant
iterative ways of looking at
things.
So we will look at it from 2
perspective.
One is that the data perspective
and the other one after the data
perspective, we will also look
at the hypothesis perspective
saying that how can we be sure
of our understanding.
So so one way in which we would
like to understand the data is
through the statistics.
So what do these statistics tell
you?
Statistics gives you many
images, so statistics tells you
that what is the mean?
What is the median?
What is the standard deviation?
What is the minimum?
What is the maximum and then it
can tell you a various
quartiles, various various
percentiles.
Uh, so there is a there are many
things that you can get from
about the data by using these
statistics.
So statistics is a form of
summarizing the data, right?
So so you you want to look at 5
people and say that this person
is the tallest among them.
So in a way you are trying to
describe them.
I mean that though that
description value is always
questionable, but then you can
always say that, OK, this among
these people, this is the
tallest.
This is the shortest and this is
the average and so on.
So, so so the looking at the
data and describing with the
help of statistics is always
something that we would like to
do when given the data.
And that summarization is
represents some form of
understanding.
So now let us go further and let
us see what happens when we get
a data.
And ohh and this is the data
that we were looking at, this
data is representing the amount
of price that the customers are
willing to pay for your product.
This is something I think many
companies will be willing to
study the market and do the
market analysis and that is the
way they can be sure that their
product will set.
Now the question is question is
that you need to understand the
patterns within the data.
So one of the common ways in
which people tend to look at the
data is in infective.
It's one of the very popular
distributions that is called
normal distribution.
It's also called Gaussian
distribution, so this normal or
Gaussian distribution assumes
that there is a mean and there
is a balanced spread across the
mean, so that is what is the
description for the data.
So now we have got this data
that is there in this at slide
and we I can also put it in the
the spreadsheet.
I hope you are able to speed the
see the spreadsheet though.
We had to make it a little.
To fit it into one piece, I need
to to.
OK, so so now you can see that
when you we try to break up and
plot a histogram with this data,
this is what it looks like.
This is what it looks like the
mean is coming to 17 point
something and the standard
deviation for the assuming the
entire population is coming as
9.88 and if you take it as a
sample it is coming as 10.1 for
these are all the functions that
are available within the within
Excel.
So so we can describe the data
this way.
But now now the question will be
that if we assume which many
times we assume that even random
data with random distribution
OK.
uh, we have a tendency to assume
that it follows a Gaussian
pattern normal pattern.
But when we follow the normal
pattern, assume the normal
pattern and this is the data.
This doesn't seem to be so good
because the normal pattern would
have liked a.
Histogram of this type.
But the histogram that we got
with the data that we observed
is very different.
And and we can also see that
once we assume a normal pattern
normal distribution, we are also
seeing that there are some
negative values because the mean
is 17 and then the standard
deviation is 10.93.
So 2 standard deviations is
straight away, putting it into
negative.
So there will be significant
values that are supposed to be
negative, yes, but the
distribution.
But as per our sample it is not.
So we need to start thinking
about what is a good
distribution that can possibly
give us some better
representation for the data that
we have and that is not really a
trivial job or an easy job.
So but but there are many, but
you are also going to have a
course on, I think statistical
methods or you are you going to
have a mathematics you're going
to have as it is a mathematics
course and possibly a statistics
course.
So the now the point is if we
are thinking about a given a
data and we want to fit in a
distribution, I'm going into the
website of a professor of Iowa
University.
So he's he has made a convenient
applet whereby we can simulate a
distribution to scene.
So now we are going into a gamma
distribution to see whether we
will be able to fit in the data
with the help of this gamma
distribution.
So now we are talking about a
data which has got a standard
deviation that is running into
ohh 10 and the mean of 17.2 and
so if we are trying out
something which is let's say
4.54, I'm going to get.
Something which is close because
which is peaking around 10 near
near about 10 and and I'm trying
to see what is the possible
percentage.
So about 10% of the items which
are above 30 and below 30 below
0, there is no item below 0 is a
0%, so it's essentially
Yeah.
everything is about about 0 uh.
Everything is about 0 and then
above 30 it is best 10%.
So it is possible that this can
be a better distribution.
So now the question is that what
is the formula by which I can
say that reject some
distribution and the other
distribution?
There is no easy answer because
we may have to do a lot of
understanding of their data.
The reason is that these two
distributions are going to give
you a different probability
density functions.
What?
Uh, OK, somebody is making a
saying something.
Uh, it also can.
I'm Ketan here.
I was not able to attend the
last Lecture till the last uh,
minute.
Can I just get a brief about
what kind of distributions are
we talking about and what
exactly standard deviation is
being used to work out?
Uh, Mr Ketan, I'm.
If you don't say I'm rude, you
have not attended the previous
class I have.
I can see there can be so many
things, so many things, but have
That till the last.
you reviewed the slides?
Yeah, I know on a high level
too.
No, not interested.
I do not know if you have
reviewed it, reviewed it to you,
may have got an idea already,
right?
Or or you didn't go through the
review?
Umm, yeah yeah.
A basic idea. Yeah.
Basic idea, yeah.
No.
OK.
OK, OK.
So.
So the point is, we did not look
at any distributions in the last
class.
So we have, we have again we
were talking about the same
topic, then we ran out of the
time.
So that is why we are reviewing
it.
So we have seen the same sample
in the last class and what we
had said is that, yes, if we try
to fit into Gaussian
distribution, so we are going to
run into trouble.
So Gaussian distribution in
detail the mathematics of that.
We are not going to go into it,
so Gaussian distribution is a
probability density function, so
that is going to give you an
indication of the probability
for various values.
So it looks like maybe I can
show another slide which is
which is giving a friend to.
What is the?
What is the Gaussian
distribution is like?
So there is a mean around which
there is a distribution and
there is a standard deviation
and typically the the normal
distribution.
These are all the standard
figures, so when you assume a
mean and standard deviation
normal, the Gaussian
distribution says that 94% data
will be within Sigma +2 Sigma 2
Sigma.
Sorry, MU minus 2 Sigma to MU +2
Sigma so 94% data will be within
that range and when you say
minus Sigma to MU the Sigma that
is a 68% data within that range.
So this is a distribution which
is used very commonly.
It's one of the most popular
distributions when we have a
random data that is for which we
got some sample or we got some
numbers but no no amount of data
is going to give you exact
distribution network.
So you need to make an
assumption and many times people
make the assumption that there
is a uniform variation on both
sides of the mean.
So so this is a.
So if we go with that
assumption, what we have seen is
that with this sample it is not
working well.
So if it is not working well,
first thing is that the sample
size itself is too small.
So we we make question ourselves
whether this sample size is
reasonable or we may just have
to start look for alternate
distributions, alternate
distributions that try to
capture the mean and standard
deviation.
But at the same time, they're
going to give you a different
type of distributions.
So this is these are all called
skewed distributions.
Normal distribution is called a
balanced distribution, which is
a balanced on both sides of the
mean, but most of the data that
the data that we see will be
skewed distribution.
Can somebody give me an example
of a skewed distribution?
Can somebody give me an example
of a skewed distribution?
If most of the data like falling
under the same range, then it is
Yes, yes, I'm asking for one
example.
Yep.
good.
One example from your website
instead of my side, why not you
someone one of you give an
example.
Reason distribution.
Why do you bring bring another
name to confuse others?
Maybe you know the Poisson
distribution, yeah.
But Bob listens of country.
Uh, I'm sorry.
Can one of you speak now?
Medical data during the COVID
time.
Income distribution.
OK.
What is that during the COVID
time?
What is the data you're talking
about?
Ohh you can just the talk about
the mortality rate during the
COVID time.
OK.
OK, fine.
Thank you, Mr Dinkar.
Any anyone has any more simpler
examples?
The the real real estate price.
Uh income distribution, Sir.
Some.
Real estate price.
OK.
Real estate price.
OK.
So, so, so say for example.
How is it going to show a skewed
distribution?
Ms I'm sorry.
Ohh yes, Mr Jagdish has got a
very interesting yes income or
salaries.
It is certainly a skewed
distribution, right?
Because when you start, there is
no negative income and it starts
with zero or maybe very small
number and once you go to some
big numbers saying that how many
people got an income more than
100 crores.
So you will say that it is
countable and, but then if you
look at the people who how many
people got income around 20,000,
you are going to get a large
number.
Yes, it is a skewed
distribution.
So as the values increase, it
has a very long positive tail.
On the positive side, very long
tail.
Yes, Mr reject this.
Thank you.
That is a very good example.
So so any anything else that
people can think of?
Populations with countries.
Population distribution.
Yeah, yes, same thing.
Yes, yes, yes, I'm Mr, I think
two people, Mr Patra and Mr
Yeah. Yeah.
Sound.
Miss Soundarya, they are saying
yes, yes, that is good.
So can you explain how the
population distribution is
skewed distribution?
One of you can take.
Yeah.
You in case of you know highly
populated like China and India,
it is quite high and and if we
go with the smaller countries.
OK.
OK, Mr Mr. Mr Patra.
OK.
OK, hold it.
Miss Soundarya, do you want to
explain how the population has
got a skewed distribution?
That's all published as usual,
like.
It also has a positive trail
with respect to yeah, that,
Positive daily, yes, yes, yes.
But then.
How do you explain it?
yeah.
And it will not be mean negative
side.
How do you?
So.
Yes, yes.
The economically stronger areas
you tend to, you know, like a
skew the population there with
higher density there.
No, no, Mr Rajesh.
Just wait.
Mr Rajesh, just wait.
Miss Soundarya, do you want to
explain it for me?
It's.
I think he had her explanation.
I have liked it so far, so can
you go further, Miss Soundarya?
Uh.
See for example with respect to
Indian states.
If I explain, there will be very
less population in a state
which.
Compared to the other states, so
we we'll have a, yeah.
We'll, we'll be OK.
Miss under.
Yeah.
No, no.
You are saying that no, I
thought actually you were
saying.
It is a long positive tail.
It is really explaining this.
Yeah.
Let me put let let me draw
population, maybe population if
I want to represent it, it will
be somewhat like this.
It will be somewhat if I
represent the population.
Let's say this is the 100 years
and this is the 80 years.
So the population will be
somewhat like or maybe the.
There will be about 120 years.
I think there is only one person
so but then as it goes down
there is a very long tail.
But then for a mortality is very
high at around 70 or I think I
for India, there will be a
different rate.
And even I think across the
regions in India also there is a
variation, some variation.
There's certainly the variation
is among the countries.
So now what you can see is that
the population will be when you
Let's.
once you reach some number, it
is almost zero, but then it is a
very long tail.
So I thought that is what Miss
Sounder you were saying.
I'd love to.
But when she talked about long
tail, but I don't know how you
will explain long tail in
another way.
Umm, it's missing that.
Yeah.
What is the other way you're
trying to explain a long tail?
What is the tail coming with?
What is your X axis and what is
your Y axis?
Uh.
With respect to states.
No, no.
Tell me X axis and Y axis.
Execs is and YX's and the.
Because it is a long and you are
plotting a distribution then
only you will get a tail, is it
not?
When you, when you are plotting
a distribution, only you are
going to get a long tail.
Is it not?
Yes, but with years, as you
explained, we'll get that most.
If you're plotting a histogram.
OK.
OK, Miss Andrea, that is fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I I think I think fine that is
fine.
OK, somebody else also wanted to
explain something else.
No, but that but that.
Uh tax regime can be the
example.
Age of retirement.
Number of World Cup Game World
Cup games winning by Indian team
this year.
OK, I don't know how what is the
aircraft is what is the Y axis.
That, that, that.
Tax.
But.
So because you are saying that
you will make a plot and it will
get a long tail.
So tax regime can be the
examples.
Yes, yes.
So the tax, yes.
OK, the people who pay high tax
will be very few.
Is that what you are saying, Mr
Devendra?
Alright, so we have a different
no, the even even we have a tax
Yeah, yeah. Great.
regime.
Buckets.
Right.
So keeping that in mind, if you
have a certain salary round of
range 0 to 50,000 so they are
lying under some certain tax lab
so that can be that these are
amount of people who has been
applicable from that range and
then from 50 to 1,00,000 they
OK.
are lying up in some.
OK, Mr.
David.
Yeah, that is fine.
I I think it is coming to
virtually the same as what one
of your colleague has said about
the income, right?
So it is virtually the income
distribution.
Right.
You're OK?
Even the age of retirement of a
person will be as in
OK, fine.
distribution.
Ease of retirement person.
There is nothing to do a
distribution there, do you?
Are you?
Can you create a distribution
there?
Like uh, age of retirement, we
can take it as an X axis and age
of the people we can take around
Y axis and most of the people
will be majority of the people
will be dying in the middle of
the 60s or older.
So, so there we can say.
Oh, OK, OK.
So you are saying that people
will retire many times?
India Government is a retirement
age of 60, but there may be some
Yes, C-16.
people who retired early and
some people will continue to
It's worked there too.
work till late.
Is that what you're OK. OK.
Uh majority will be dying on 16
meter of the 60, so there we can
say hi negatively skewed
distribution over there even.
Alright, maybe that he getting
sales as well can be the
Uh, OK, OK.
example, like on a certain date
range, the ticket sales got a
very high amount of frequency of
the booking.
Yeah.
OK.
So that can also be the example.
Hmm.
Yes, yes, yes.
Right, right, right.
So I yes.
Passcode and examination.
Marks coordinates.
Yeah, yeah, fine.
Fine.
Yeah, yeah, alright.
OK.
Thank you.
I think we by now I think
everybody has understood what is
the, what is the the long tail
we are talking about what is the
mean around which the
distribution we are considering
and then when do we say it is
symmetric and when do we say
symmetric and So what is
symmetric and then and then we
have also seen that many
examples where we have an
asymmetric or a skewed
distribution.
So, so far so good.
So I think I think I think it
is, but well spent.
So now what we are saying is
that in such cases we have a far
more complex, but things to
explain.
So in case of when we assume it
is a normal distribution, so we
are trying to compute the
probability of how many people
will be willing to pay more than
30.
So we got some answer, but when
it is gamma distribution, you
can keep tuning alpha and beta
and then you are going to get a
different types of values with
respect to how many more people
will be, how many people will be
willing to pay more than $30.00.
So so I think I hope that gives
you a fair understanding of how
to look at the data when you get
some numbers and how much
conclusion you can draw and how
much confidence you will have
you.
It's possible that we are not
trying to measure the
confidence, but you can see that
when the population is small,
then you start suspecting that.
Have you got the distribution
right?
It is always a questionable that
with small population when
you're trying to formulate a
distribution, it may not be
good, but then there are many
methods which assume that you
can compute a probability that X
will be greater than something,
or X will be less than this.
So in order for you to give a
give a output pattern.
So.
So in such cases you just have
to take it with the.
If you think your data is
insufficient, then you have to
take it with a pinch of salt.
So you just have to keep trying
and then finally, finally, you
need to make an assumption and
you need to accept the result.
But can you talk once more?
How did you move from that
skewed data to gamma
distribution?
What all did you do to and what
floating was done?
No, nothing.
We did nothing.
All we said is that all we said
is that now the data doesn't
look balanced.
Why not try a gamma
distribution?
So how do we get to
commoditization though?
What?
What do we do?
So let's say we do with that of
1000, you know employees, which
Uh.
You know there is, there is no
there.
is skewed.
There is no formula, so since.
So how did you get the Gaussian
distribution within an
assumption right?
Similarly, gamma distribution is
an assumption which is based on
alpha and beta parameters.
And what are alpha and beta
parameters?
Also beta parameters is you can
see in the I have given the
formula and this is the formula
and gamma alpha function is
actually it is a factorial
function on alpha so so this is
the.
This is the what is the function
and for normal distribution?
I think I may have given in
another slide deck, so normal
distribution this is this is the
format.
So we around X.
This is the MU, MU is the mean
around mean.
You are assuming that it is
distributed on both sides, with
the A spread controlled by
signal.
I mean it would.
Are who who?
Would there be any tool or
something that we would be able
Can you?
Who is talking OK, Mr SUMIT?
to use whether you know it is
normal distributed or not?
How do we practically use it
for?
No, no, that is what I'm telling
now.
I'm trying to understand.
You need to know about your
data.
That is what now you want to
discover patterns in your data.
If you don't know your data,
then you need to be
uncomfortable.
Is it not?
Nobody is saying that you do one
pattern because The thing is
that the data exists as it is.
It is not.
It mean see.
OK.
Maybe.
Maybe, Mr SUMIT, I think you are
really looking for an answer
which is but which is I think a
philosophical answer.
I think that is what you're
looking for.
You know, I'm looking for
practical answer.
So can we say this the this?
Because because because The
thing is that what you are
Maybe it would come later.
saying is I think this is what
you are saying, right?
OK.
All models are wrong, but some
are useful and now that is it is
your responsibility to find out
which is more useful.
There is no no simple formula.
There is no simple formula
saying that population.
I will take Gaussian
distribution.
What will happen?
So you can imagine you are also
a experience with professional
right?
You can imagine what will
happen.
Suppose you take the salaries as
simple Gaussian distribution
balanced Gaussian distribution.
So now the question is that yes,
the model will be wrong.
So can we?
But even if you take gamma
distribution, there will be
there will be an approximation,
but it may be more useful than
Gaussian.
Is it not?
Is that are you In Sync or
you're really trying to say
So.
something else?
I think somewhat, but not fully.
Mr.
Smith, are you trying to say
something else or or you are
saying that you are?
You are seeing that yes, data
requires a diligence.
I was just trying to make
practical sense of how do we get
No, no there is not.
to something else if yeah.
See the practical sense is that
everything we talked about is
practical.
Is it not?
The income is practical.
Is is practical and all
distributions are, because if
the Government of India is
trying to make a plot, it is
practical.
Is it not so?
It has got a billion people and
it is plotting the age, but then
what you get is that there you
cannot.
But there in this case it is.
You can say that it is very
simple.
It is not a a symmetric
distribution, but then what do
what I'm saying is that in your
own company, if you have data
now, you would responsibility to
see that you want to minimize
the error.
So you have to try all all
possible things available to
you.
Is it not?
OK, OK.
But if I make if I make a, if I
make an, you put it.
Clean, but I've been sick.
Mr Rajesh, yes, go ahead.
If I make can we put it this
way, Sir?
How do we go from gas to
Gaussian to beta distribution?
Educated guesses what?
No, no, no, no.
This is just listen, listen, we
are not going from anywhere to
anywhere.
We have looked at Gaussian
distribution and Gaussian
distribution.
We we can see that when we plot
the Gaussian distribution, when
we look at the histogram, it
seems to be odd.
So.
So we thought that, OK, why not
we try another distribution,
that doesn't mean that this this
data is exactly following the
new distribution.
Is that clear?
They so basically like to answer
the question, can we say it's an
educated guess?
We have to continually make
until we reach, yeah.
Yes, that is right.
Yes, actually you need to have a
that affinity for the data.
That is what not you.
So you are going to be a data
scientist with so many numbers,
so you just need to keep looking
at the data and seeing that what
is the best way I understand it.
I agree because if there was a
formula, there wouldn't be need
for data science or practical
formula.
That is right, absolutely right.
Absolutely right.
Because it's it's in fact, I
think that whatever that
philosopher said about the
models is, I think I I'm sure
you people know it.
So the model you know model can
be perfect so so but then you
need to see, you need to still
depend on some model to
represent some.
Alright, so we will, we will
proceed with another one.
This is more to do with the.
This is a.
This is so we talked about data
and trying to model.
So now we are trying to look at
how do we get a hypothesis and
how can we be sure about the
hypothesis.
So now let us look at a some
information.
So I think all of us know about
this.
This slide I don't need to
explain.
If somebody is having doubt, you
can ask, but I don't think I
need to explain.
So can I ask a quick question?
Yes, sure.
Sure, why not?
Uh, so you weren't using two
slides to when you were doing
for the formulas?
Is is it there in the module
section?
Ohh I don't know, I don't know
what is the question.
I have not understood the
question.
To you, you are using two slaves
right to show the one you used
for representing the formulas.
Ohh.
OK, OK.
Just one minute I think.
Uh.
The gamma distribution formula
is in a slide deck two and then
the Gaussian distribution
formalized in slide deck 3.
Is that correct?
That is what you're saying,
right?
33 yeah, yeah. So.
Yeah.
No, no, you will have both of
them.
Yeah, you will have because that
was the coming from the last
After this.
class, last class.
We could not complete the
slides, so that is why there are
some slides.
OK.
Somebody else has having some
question.
OK, so let's proceed.
So, Sir, can we use those
formulas to calculate, uh,
something like a Live like how
to use those formulas?
No, they there is nothing to
know about using the formula.
The point is that these formula
is, so these are the very
popular formulas in statistical
distributions.
So very, very popular
mathematical formulas.
So when you take this formula
and try to plot the density
Again.
function X along the X axis and
density function along Y axis,
FX along the Y axis, this is the
shape that you will get.
So nothing else.
So I do not know what is the
question you are asking.
But I I you know when when we do
have a huge set of data would
Like.
put there be some functions so
tools available to technically
Hmm.
apply this formula to get to
that distribution.
Yeah.
Maybe we will talk about how to
how to look at the data and then
that give me we may come back
because in the slide deck three,
I looked at a little bit about
the distribution and then the
shape of the distribution a
little bit.
But then there is no formula
anywhere, no formula.
Actually, I will also look at
maybe maybe I will bring in two
elements, maybe that helps you
suppose that I have a I have the
distribution of data and state
normal distribution.
Suppose I take.
Then I should get a skew OF0 and
kurtosis of zero.
When I use the Excel functions
on that data so.
So if you have a data that is
not coming, so it tells that it
is not normal distribution.
It is not very close to normal
distribution, but then it
because we do not have too many
formulas.
So we have got either one
distribution or other
distribution.
So we have to go with one of
them.
So you don't have a many
choices.
There are only three or four
popular distributions that
people use, so you have to live
with one of them.
A.
What do you mean by Q? Tosis,
Sir?
Yeah, I'll.
I'll come to that in a short
I'll come to that in a it is
Yeah, OK.
just indicating I I think I have
another slide to show the
quotes, but don't expect too
much.
It is just saying that instead
of normal distribution, it is
simply a variant of a normal
distribution.
And said that the particulars in
the.
OK.
Mr Rajesh, is this an answer or
a question?
I'm because it's a long thing,
Mr Rajesh.
And that was that was an answer
to someone.
Why you have to speak up?
Somebody asked.
OK. OK.
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much. Alright.
Uh, so just I want to know the
formula.
The simple formulas in the Excel
that is mean and given the range
of the data and that is the
formula or something else.
Yet the mean is equal to C you
can always compute.
For example, I have a
spreadsheet, so all I do is that
I want to compute the mean.
I don't even go to the formula
for the mean.
So you can see at the bottom
there is an average that is that
you can straight to put it as a
mean but standard deviation.
You need to take the formula
which is.
It has available in standard
deviation and standard deviation
with PS as a population standard
deviation.
Yes, as a sample.
So it tells you the formula, so
that is not a big deal, so I can
safely give it a pass saying
that.
OK, so when you have a data,
yeah, you need the you need to
be able to compute these these
things.
But then and you better it is a
normal distribution or not is
better understood by looking at
things like skew and kurtosis,
but they are not going to tell
you that.
What is the what you should do?
It is only telling you that.
OK, it maybe normal distribution
is not safe, but but there is no
formula because so many times
this is you think that the
sample itself is not big enough.
So you may simply make some
assumptions.
OK, this slide is it clear.
I hope it is clear.
I anyway, you, all of us are at
the same page.
The total awareness program is
something which the government
initially thought, why not?
We use the data and data science
to catch terrorists.
So that is the that is the
purpose of total awareness
program.
So now what is the problem that
do you see when you have a
program like that?
Because they are seeing total
awareness program, they have
every data related to terrorist
but then still they could not
catch the terrorist.
Still, they did the job.
On September 1128.
Because they might be having
completely a discrete set of
data that cannot be accompanied
with us some certain conclusion.
Didn't know what they're looking
for.
OK.
Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
That is, I think, yeah, I think
these are good answers.
Let us proceed little further.
Maybe.
Maybe we'll see.
We'll see.
What?
What is the?
What are the other?
I think these two are both are
good points.
So now let us look at a
principle that is called
Bonferroni principle.
So what it says is that you have
a large volume of data and and
then you are trying to find
discover a pattern from that
data.
And even if the data is random,
even if the data is random, you
may start seeing some patterns.
You may still start seeing that
setting events or second type
are happening.
So now let us look at an
example.
Suppose that there is a country
with 1 billion people, OK, and
and then the government has no
option and they want to catch
any terrorist all over anyone,
anywhere in the country.
So everybody is a potential able
do it.
So everybody is a potential
terrorist and now they started
using the logic that the total
awareness program with saying
that, OK, we have the hotel
records, credit card receipts,
travel data.
So OK, why not use it?
So let us say everybody goes to
a hotel on 1% of the days Monday
in 100 days and then a hotel
holds 100 people.
So that means they can't.
The country has at least 100,000
hotels, so let us take for
simplicity 100,000 hotels are
there and hotel holds 100
people.
So they're 10 million people
that hotel can hold and
everybody goes to hotel in 100
days.
So 1 billion population.
So it is well, it is perfect
situation.
So now, now we let us say we are
examining the hotel records for
three years because the because
we know that the terrorists
require a lead time before they
perform the dangerous things.
So we want to study the hotel
records for 1000 days.
So now we create a hypothesis.
We create a hypothesis 2 people
who on two different days stay
at the same hotel.
Does it look like a failed
hypothesis?
No.
So we are suspecting.
We are suspecting the evil
doers.
It doesn't.
If we see that two people on two
different days stayed at the
same.
Uh.
I.
Someone might have referred the
other guy to use the hotel, so
like they were visiting same
places.
No, there should be normal here.
No, but how will the government
find out?
So what is the hypothesis you
give it to them?
Because they have all credit
card data, they have hotel data.
They have every data, but what
hypothesis you will give them if
they want to catch terrorists?
So now let us say they took the
hypothesis.
OK.
Maybe.
Maybe there are problems, but
then let us say they took the
hypothesis.
So now let us compute what is
going to happen.
Hello.
So the probability of a person
visiting a hotel it is simple
.01 OK?
And two people deciding to go to
the hotel on same day any same
day is 10 to the power of minus
four because for every person
the probability is .01.
So two arbitrary random people,
they're going to the hotel on
the same day, 10 to the power of
minus four.
And now they don't.
100,000 hotels, so the
probability of going to the same
hotel is 10 to the power minus
five.
So it is 10 to the power of
minus nine that two people are
probability of two arbitrary
people are visiting the same
hotel.
OK, so now these probability
that the same two people with
visit the same hotel on and two
different days is tender for a
-, 9 * 10 to the power minus
nine.
So we got 10 to the power of
minus 18.
So far so good.
It looks like a rare event, so
now let us look at relation.
The population is 10 to the 49.
OK, so I'm I'm hearing some
noise.
I'm going to mute you people for
five minutes and after that I
will unmute.
So meanwhile you can keep
typing, not not a problem, and
I'll catch up with you.
So it is fine.
So they'll population is 10 to
the power from 9.
So what is the the combination
page number of pages 10 to the
power of 9?
So and then and then what else?
C2, right?
Any two combinations.
So what is the value of N C2?
This is equal to n -, 1 /, 2.
So this is approximately 5 into
10 to the power of 17 represents
the number of pages of people
and the number of pairs of days
that is there is 5 into 10 to
the power of 5.
So again, this is 10 to the
power of three days.
So you start picking up the
pages of the days 10 to the
power of 5 into 10 to the power
of 5.
So the expected number of events
that look like it will doing is
product of the number of pairs
of people, number of pairs of
days and the probability that
any pair of the people and pair
of these is an instance of the
behavior as per our hypothesis.
So now we are saying this is the
possible number of pairs.
This is the possible page of
days and then this is the
probability that given a paid,
what is the probability that
they will go to a hotel on the
same day within the 1000 days
period, which is the day of
study.
So twice twice they go to the
same model.
The probability is 1/4 million.
So now, now the challenge is 1/4
million probabilities that they
they are all suspicious.
So what is the cost of this
changing quarter million people?
It is enormous for any
government because they have to
start looking for those all
those quarter million people,
they have to start looking at
their antecedents.
What are?
What is their background?
What type of work they do and
what type of money they have?
What type of money that they
receive and then what type of
communication that they're doing
and who are the people that they
are talking to?
And so it is not easy if to a
police station.
Suppose that you are going to
report.
I saw in a city of 1,000,000
people if five people go and
report every day saying that,
OK, there is a theft in our host
and investigate it is fine.
But on one day, if 100,000
people go to the police station
and complain that theft happened
in our house, catch the thieves.
The police station simply has to
raise their hands because it's
impossible for them to handle
that case load.
So now we are saying that in the
country there are quarter
million suspicious terrorist
suspected terrorists.
So you need to find everything
about them so that you can
conclude that what is the the
plan of action.
So this is a virtually an
impossible task, even for a rich
or the very resourceful
governments like US or some
other advanced countries with
huge intelligence and and the
stuff.
So so now the question is that
what is the problem?
So now let us say, let us change
the hypothesis.
Let it change the hypothesis.
So we say that the two people on
three different days were at the
same hotel.
So now we had the same data, so
the probability of the same two
people will be in the same hotel
on three different days is 10 to
the power minus 27 and the
expected number of events that
look like you were doing is 2.5
and 10 to the power minus four.
So here, here, any police
station will be able to handle
if this is what you're going to
get.
Ohh no, no, no.
Let me unmute you people and see
what what is it that you are
observed.
So nobody has typed anything, so
I'm just opening the discussion.
What do you think?
What do you what have you
observed?
No, the morgue.
So can we?
Can we assume this way that
motor listed the probability
The.
mode will be the accuracy that
we are moving in the right
direction?
Yeah, but how do you know that
lesser the the probability
you're going in the right
direction?
How do you know that?
So so now the first thing is
that first thing is that OK, now
But like like.
That.
let us be clear.
The American Government never
wanted the 9/11 to happen.
If they had resources, or if
they had slightest suspicion,
they would have prevented,
because that is a once in a
century event, it's not even
once in a decade event such
events so rarely occur, so they
would have put in everything
they would have spent billion
dollars or $100 billion to
prevent it.
So now the question is that who
will give them a hypothesis that
is going to help them?
Yes, Mr someone wants to say
something.
So whatever else less is our
data set, I mean whatever is
Still.
that we get?
How much we can reduce the data
set would be helpful.
I mean, so if this is.
No, no, it is not a question of
if you reduce the data set.
Obviously you may be losing some
valuable data because here we
I mean if.
are saying that the the question
the problem that the book is
talking about is that there was
all the data that is available
to the government, but still
they could not prevent it
because they they because some
of the data could have been
suspected.
But but then what is really
missing?
Because we are looking at 2
possible hypothesis and the
results that come out of the two
hypothesis.
The better the have hypothesis,
more information we can extract
from the data or easily we can
extract.
Absolutely.
Absolutely the if the hypothesis
is better, it is good.
But who is capable of giving a
right hypothesis?
Yes.
Same branch.
And yes, yes, yes, please.
It talking about owning data.
Let us antist.
Maybe someone who is analyzed
the data.
OK, OK.
So so now now my question to
Miss GURSIMRAN Kaur.
I think you are you are talking
about the so.
Yes.
So now what you are saying is
that it the US could have
prevented the the event is that
is that right?
Is that what you are hypothesis
or is it your conclusion based
on all this?
No, no, Sir.
Actually, based on the like
examples given, so as like the
better our hypothesis, the more
information we can extract from
the data Friday seen the data or
analyzed it, maybe they could
have prevented.
OK, OK, alright.
So Sir, the data set could not
be the conclusive enough that we
can find out any solution, or at
least we can.
Uh, do some kind of a.
Yes, yes, the the situation is
not the giving.
So it's.
A hypothesis itself is not easy.
So many times, you may say that,
OK, the business analyst has to
give me a hypothesis and I'm
going to work with it.
And then I'm going to to get
some patterns where our either
prove or disprove the hypothesis
with the help of the data.
So that is what you are you like
to do with the data because
somebody gives a hypothesis,
then you can either prove or
disprove.
For example, some suppose that
you have to sell some products,
so somebody gives you an
hypothesis that, OK, the people
with higher income are going to
buy.
Maybe you want to prove or
disprove or similarly you may
want to say that OK, if the
father buys a product, the son
or daughter daughter is likely
to buy the product, so maybe
that's a hypothesis that you
want to prove or disprove with
the data.
But the question is that the
quality of hypothesis itself is
always is so many times is a
problem.
It's not easy to get a good
hypothesis, and this hypothesis
it the the hypothesis is
becoming even bigger problems
when you are dealing with a
really a multi dimensional data
because the data has a huge
dimensionality and then the
assuming that the damage the
attributes that you are dealing
with are all independent uh,
creating a hypothesis that you
want to prove or disprove is not
an easy job.
So if you got, if you appreciate
that point, I think possibly
this example would have served
the purpose.
Yeah, exactly.
So I think like both the
hypothesis, the first one and
the second one does make sense,
but test proving or disproving
the first hypothesis is very
difficult because we can't
verify the background of quarter
million of people.
But in the second case, there
are less number of people that
we want to check the background
because it is even reader to see
two arbitrary people in the same
hotel at three different
instances.
So that is a little bit better
hypothesis that we can prove or
disprove.
OK.
OK, fine.
But two.
Fine, nothing.
I have nothing to say.
Yeah, sure. OK.
OK. OK.
There's no reference.
So so we got some idea that the
hypothesis itself can be the
culprit sometimes, but the data
is understanding the data is a
is a challenge many times.
OK.
So let's proceed further.
So we will look at really what
is known as data pipeline.
So in fact, we have briefly
looked at it in the first
session.
I think in the first session let
me go to the slide deck that we
used in the first session.
I think we had.
Kind of looked at, I think I had
looked at this is the.
This is the URL I had used.
SO11 quick question or
clarification so that Ben
Yes, yes, go ahead.
Yeah, yeah, go ahead.
Ferroni principle, whatever that
was, so that basically is
pointing to the same that
hypothesis can have problem
that's what that principle is.
Is that what we are saying?
Ohh and see what it is saying is
that if the data size is large
it is a problem.
That is what it is saying when
the data size is large, you are
OK.
That that.
you are going to run problems
with the false positives and
That itself is that principle.
false negatives and yeah.
OK.
OK. OK.
And and So what it means is that
the you may find a very odd
Thank you.
patterns also start showing up.
Yep, got it. Yeah.
Uh.
Through randomness through
randomness.
OK.
Thank you.
OK.
So.
So we had seen the enterprise
data architecture, enterprise
data architecture.
OK.
Thank you.
Mr Raghavendra is actually
Professor Raghavendra, is one of
the teaching assistants for the
section.
So Professor Ravindra, thank you
for joining this session.
So you can unmute yourself and
you can speak.
I think you are unmuted.
Ohh you look good.
Are you dead?
What?
You are dead.
Well, look, I'm good.
Like, OK, you are there.
So you can answer some of the
questions in the chat window if
you if you see that anything
that you can clarify.
Yeah, alright.
Alright.
We look at the data pipelines is
in fact the concept is coming
from the enterprise
architecture.
Enterprise have many types of
data sources, so we can say when
you say relational database it
is not in a big enterprise which
is a multinational enterprise.
It is possible that they may be
using four or five types of
relational databases, and they
may be using ten types of non
relational databases and they
may be using many, many other
types of data stores and data
processing mechanisms.
So in that sense, when we have
this type of situation, so we
need to be having data pipelines
in order to connect the data
within the enterprise.
So that is the that is what we
want to briefly look at.
So the data pipelines they need
to perform several things.
For example, they they'll have
to do an extraction of the data
from one source and may have to
validate the data and the
deliver the data to a
destination and and very often
we associate the designation of
data engineers with respect to
ohh with respect to.
Be be there with respect to the
people who perform the manage
the data pipelines and one of
the skills that they expect is
the SQL and they may have to
connect to data warehouse.
They may have to connect to data
leak and so they are going to
produce the pipelines which are
connecting the various sources
and one of the output that they
generate may be a dashboard.
So very often the organizations
require a dashboard that gives
them a real picture of the
status of business.
So for many key parameters will
be there for many cxos say they
will be looking for some the
business performance with
respect to some parameters.
So in such cases you will have
to generate a dashboard through
various data pipelines and then
that is going to be it can be a
dashboard, can have many
metrics, not necessarily single
metrics and that can come from
multiple sources.
So you need to have the ability
to perform they receive the data
from multiple sources, clean
structure, normalize, combine,
aggregate, anonymize or secure.
So now my question is that any
word which is troubling you.
Any word is troubling you.
What is anonymize here?
I know and no, no, right.
Anonymize is that sometimes the
data that you want to you may
have the concern that you are
guaranteeing the privacy.
For example, when we take the
feedback about the course, we
say that it is an anonymous
feedback, so we get the scores,
but then we don't know what is
the score.
Similarly, there are many times
you have to anonymize the data.
Venkata is it like masking the
data.
One can be masking data, so
sometimes you may have to remove
the, remove the users username
or the source of the data.
So it depends on the purpose for
which you're using it.
I'm not saying that for creating
a dashboard you need to
anonymous, but then it may
require because the customer
names should not be disclosed.
So for example, in a bank
balance, you want to know the
aggregate balances in a certain
branch, but obviously you are.
The bank is obliged to keep the,
let's say your balance secret.
So on except for your
relationship manager, they can
make sure that other people will
not get to see your balance.
So that is one possibility.
I'm not sure whether all the
banks have the same rule or some
banks.
Are they?
I don't know what is the rule,
but then when you have to
maintain the confidentiality,
yes it becomes a required.
Uh, I hope we are In Sync.
Can you please go back to the
slide for a moment there any
OK, go back to this slide.
other?
I'm going back, yes.
OK.
Thank you.
OK, I think we are fine.
So we are going to the next.
Just so just one one doubt
please.
So what is yes.
Sorry.
Uh, will you be able to?
Yeah, it worked.
What do you mean by normalized?
See, the normalized is
interesting phenomenon.
No.
So we we get the data from many
of many parameters and sometimes
what we want to do is that we
need to combine them in order to
Umm.
get a suitable result.
So suppose that there is a.
Umm.
There is a there is a gadget
that is that you have to sell
and do you think that two
parameters are going to
In.
different decide whether the
person will buy a gadget.
One is easy and other is inco.
Umm.
Years of your potential
customers is 20 to 80 and income
OK.
of your potential customers is
10,200 crores.
So now do you see the problem
when you want to combine the two
Yeah, the yes, yes, you have a
very huge, huge amount of, you
Mr Saurabh, DC DC the problem.
know, the the what you 100,000
something you told right salary
Income range income range can be
much bigger than the age range.
8, income range.
Yeah.
So that is out of range, right?
You meant to say that is out of
range.
So so you still have to, you
have to combine the two in order
to get because what we are
saying is we think is that both
the attributes are important for
your gadget.
Umm.
Then, Venkat said.
I'm I'm very much sorry.
Just I'm just out of curiosity
then in such cases we have to
just ignore such type of data
which is out of range right?
No, no, there is nothing like
out of range.
To make the things so.
No, no, Mr Gautam.
Mr Saurav, there is nothing is
out of range.
Umm.
So I am saying you have
customers who have got income
from 10,000 rupees, 200 crore
rupees and you have customers
OK.
who are in their range of 20 to
80 and your gadget for selling
OK.
the gadget.
You think that both are
important.
That is what you think there is.
Umm OK.
That is what many times happens,
right?
Yes, yes.
So now you have to combine these
two to give a result of yes or
Umm, yeah yeah, I understood.
no whether this person is going
to buy or not.
So that, yeah.
So that's what normalization we
are doing trying to do to make
You you have to do how to do it.
it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We you don't worry about it, but
some normalization we have to do
God.
before you can combine that
correct.
Yeah, got it.
Got it.
Got it, Sir.
Thank you.
OK.
Yeah.
Please proceed. Yeah.
Alright, so the pipeline will
have several stages.
So as we discussed, the pipeline
will connecting the mini data
sources and mini data syncs.
So we need to take extract right
there is a pipeline will extract
data from one source using
several mechanisms and there may
be multiple steps involved in
extraction and then data
preprocessing can involve any
type of processing that we
talked about then validation and
then we need to run the machine
learning model on the data and
then the model may be the what
the final consumer is looking
at.
And and then we are talking
about the data ingestion.
Uh refers to the extracting data
from one source, so this is the
and then I think these are all
the examples of tools, so we
don't need to go into that.
So typically we'll have the
pipelines will be of the type
two types, 2 broad types, ETL.
Or 80.
So typically ETL is something
big which puts the data into a
structured data sync like
warehouse which can give you a
enable, a OLAP processing or the
business intelligence.
And then ELT is generally the
sink is more of the form of data
leak, which takes the data of
any type and just holds it and
you transform it only when you
need to start working with it or
processing it.
But then this is not really a
rule.
So what we are saying is that we
can have two types of the
pipelines which are doing ETL
sequence or eltc sequence.
So can you please give an
example for ELT?
You know.
No, that is what now ELT is
saying that we are putting the
data into somewhere and do the
transformation later so that we
will get the pattern or or graph
or whatever you want.
So transform you postpone in ELT
and in ETL, you first perform
the transform and then only you
do the loading.
Is that clear?
So where is data warehouse in
ELT?
No, no data warehouse is acting
as a sink in this case.
So because there are data from
many sources and you want to put
them in data warehouse because
data warehouse is used for
online analytical process.
Is that clear?
Or still some questions?
Yeah.
So like when we say that data
warehouse will be used for
analytical processing.
So for ETL like the data
warehouse is the last step right
where the data gets loaded in
data warehouse and that there it
That is right.
That is right, yeah.
can be used for OLAP processing.
Yeah, right.
But when it comes to ELT there,
I mean I understand that, OK,
like after extraction the data
is being put in Data Lake and
then transformation is happening
so.
Umm.
Transformation can be of various
types and it can be by various
syncs and each sync may have a
different type of
transformation.
OK.
And are we saying that after
transformation the data will go
to the uh?
Data warehouse where OLAP can
happen in ELT as well.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
When we say ELT, we are trying
to say that we first load the
Umm.
data into the into some place.
So which is, let's say data leak
without doing any
transformations.
So it is more like a raw data
and then transformation will be
done when you need it.
So where is OLAP happening in
ELT?
No, we know OLAP OLAP may not
happen in the Lt because he OLAP
requests that the data is
structured and is as per some
certain format.
Because data warehouse you know
is typically relational.
OK.
Is that clear?
Got it.
Yep, Yep.
Thank you.
By that way, ELO process would
be would be more faster than
than the ETL process, right?
Yeah, possible that is quite
possible, right?
OK.
OK, so there's nothing here.
So we are talking about
transformation can require
analytical knowledge.
So you may involve somebody who
has expertise in how the data is
used for various purposes, but
extract and load maybe simply
set of scripts or programs so
that a data engineer may be
better here.
But then I'll leave it because
the companies can have
designations of various kinds,
so it is just a secretive kind
of picture.
And we need to orchestrate the
pipelines so the pipelines are
are because they are controlled
so, so, so many times there are
data sources from which you
cannot pull out the data during
certain hours because you cannot
guarantee sistance accepted
certain point of time and then
it is possible that for
performance reasons also they do
not allow you to do the
extraction.
Uh.
During the during certain hours,
so there can be several things
and orchestration may also
involve several aspects with
respect to managing as the what
data flows.
And and the the data sources can
be innumerable.
Most.
So this is the example the our
colleague has taken from
Right.
Is there any?
Tableau.
So this is just a giving an
indication that there is a large
Step.
number of possible sources that
you talk about.
So and but there are tools which
deal with these hundreds of
The artist is.
sources.
Effective.
OK, someone is having a
question.
I said I did not get the how to
orchestrating the data there
and.
No, no, I did not discuss even
because orchestrating is that in
the pipeline, we may have to do
the management depending on the
source and sync and the data
requirement.
So so the orchestration can be
something.
For example, you want to stop
the data at certain place or
allow it to flow.
It's a 10 place you want to
buffer it at certain certain
things, and you may control the
flows to certain places so there
can be several things.
OK, so so now I hope.
OK.
And just one more thing.
So the ETL and the E ELT that
you have explained.
So is it like both other ways?
Can we followed up to do the
whole app transformation?
No, OLAP is not the only only
way in which we do the
analytics.
For example, Data Lake, we can
directly use for performing many
of the data science tasks.
We can straight away take the
data from data leak and start
doing it, but in that case we
need to do many types of
preprocessing.
Each preprocessing for each task
can be varying.
For example, if you are trying
to do a regression, you may do a
preprocessing in certain way.
If you want to do clustering,
you may do it in different way,
so there can be many types of
preprocessing that you may have
to do and depending on the types
of targets or the types of goal
that you have to do.
Uh.
Is that is that?
OK.
Does that clarify or?
OK.
So that you mean, so ETL and ELT
is one of those processes of
doing that kind of
transformation, I mean.
See that T is standing for
transformation?
I said that that can also be a
preprocessing.
Right.
The preprocessing is that for
example, you want to build a
Right.
classifier and beerby you will
predict whether somebody will
buy the gadget that your company
has manufactured.
So now the question is that that
is a that you are trying to
Right, right, right.
build a classifier for that you
need to you need the data.
The data may be available in
data leak, but for performing
Umm.
your task you may need to do
many preprocessing steps before
you can go do the task.
Does that help?
Right, right.
It helps us.
Thank you, Sir. Thank.
OK, OK.
So now what we do is we are more
than one hour.
So let us take a 5 minute break.
Let's get restarted.
So we want to understand the
data with the help of some
statistical descriptions.
So we that uh, the data first
has to be understood before we
can model it.
So let us see what are the
common ways in which we can
describe the data.
OK, so so the what is the
purpose of creating the
statistical descriptions?
But was for this motivation is
understanding the central
tendency variation spread.
So so how how are we capturing
uh, the characteristics?
So the common measures include
all of these.
Be min, Max, median and I I hope
other one which is not put but
then mean is common right and
mood is also common.
Mood is the most frequently what
is the value it takes? OK.
And so.
So this is going to help us if
we have got the understood it
with the the certain precision
when we are able to analyze it
with certain level of precision.
So this is really a challenge
because the granularity is very
often achieved only way for we
have a large volume of data.
And and then sometimes we may
have to convert the majors into
some form of numerical
dimensions in order to be able
to express that using.
Using the statistical
descriptions.
And we are going to see what is
the meaning of box plot and what
is the meaning of quantile
analysis in a short way.
So let us look at the
definitions for sitting in the
measurements of central
tendency.
So this is representing the mean
X bar very often many authors
write, but don't be surprised if
somebody uses another
nomenclature, but the mean is we
are taking let's say there is a
sample of size 100.
Ohh element so one by yen, then
multiplied by the sum of the
elements so that is going to be
mean.
So when it is for the entire
population, some authors use MU.
So in that case, some of the
values for all the population
and divided by the size of the
population.
And so small and it's sample and
begin is population size.
So this is a convention.
So, but don't be don't be
disappointed if somebody doesn't
follow that strictly, but there
is a interesting thing that you
may want to do is to create a
weighted arithmetic mean.
So by creating the weights.
Ohh So what you are saying is
that you are trying to give more
importance to certain elements
in the data compared to the
other.
There is also a concept that you
may use.
A trim would mean and this is a
example, is a is for example, in
Olympics there are for certain
events.
Suppose that there are 7 judges
and they give a score like this.
So there are seven judges.
They give the scores to some
gymnast like this.
So what they do is that they
chop this and they chop this and
they take the average of this
and say that the gymnast is
getting a score of 8.33.
So.
So what they think is that these
some very low scores are very
low.
High scores may have been may
have some element of bias, so
they would rather take a chop
off some of them and take the
mean of the remaining scores.
The median is an interesting
number.
We had talked about it.
So when we have certain values.
So suppose that there is a town
and we are looking at.
Let's take the example of
income.
There is an example of ages
right below, so let's look at
the the let's say 10K is the
salary of some people, 11K of
somebody 12K of somebody, then
13 K of somebody and then and
then somebody has an income of
100K.
This is the income of the people
in a small town.
So what will be the mean?
If this is the entire
population, what you get is a
2535 forty 646 / 5 is the mean
is 146 right?
So it is 29.2.
This is the main so this doesn't
seem to represent the city, the
population of the area well, but
this is the middle number.
This may be a better
representation of the
population.
The income of the people, so
which is the median so median
has the advantage that it can
reject the extreme presence of
extreme values and stick to the
core data and then stay with the
central tendency of the core
data where by eliminating
automatically trimming out the
extremes.
Uh, so far are we good?
Ohk.
OK, OK.
I think thank you for.
Yeah.
Thank you.
There are some questions which
have been answered.
OK, good.
Alright, so so fine.
Uh, Mr Soumya charandas.
You think the median is a is a
different, different thing 11.5.
No, no.
There are five numbers, so 1011,
twelve 1300.
So the median will be 12, right?
Mr Sonya, are you fine?
You know various 5 1/2.
There are five elements, not
five and half.
Umm.
OK, fine.
Thank you.
Thank you.
Yeah, alright.
OK, OK.
So so now, now let us say ohh,
OK that is fine now.
So I had muted you in the break.
So do you want me to give a you
want me to open that, let's say.
OK.
OK, let us proceed further.
I think everything is clear so
forth.
So now we may have a different
situation, so we are not getting
individual data.
We have only got a histogram, so
the histogram plot is like this.
So so the histogram.
We can plot plot for this data.
So histogram is telling us this.
So with the one to five, they
are 200 people 6 to 15.
Then 16 to 20 there are
different ranges that 21 to 50.
And 51 to 80 and 81 to 110.
OK, so now what we are saying is
that there are 200 people here.
Then there are 450 people in
this range.
And 300 people in this range
then 1500 people in this range
and 700 people in this range and
44 people in this range.
So now you have got a histogram,
but you need to get the median.
So now what you know is that the
median number is such that there
will be more as many people
above it at as many people below
it.
So first you need to find which
range is capturing the medium.
So now you have a total number
of population that you can make
which is 206, fifty 950 and then
1650.
So the median will be within
this interval, right?
So when you compute it, because
this is a broad, it is going to
capture it, and once you do that
then you will compute the median
using this varial one is
representing the lower end of
the range.
Bless Yen by two is the total
size of the population.
Yen is the total population and
by two is half of that minus the
frequency before the before this
interval divided by the size of
the interval.
Divided by the.
Frequency of the median so.
Just one minute the the width.
So this multiple minus this.
So the frequency of the uh, let
me just capture this.
So this minus this?
L1 is 21.
L1 is 20 plus the north by two
minus the Sigma of the people.
So this is representing a the
the people.
Then you are looking at.
The width of the OK the width is
width is 2150 -.
21 OK, so the width is
representing the age, age and
then this is the actual
frequency of that median
interval.
So that is how you will have you
can find when you have only a
histogram, you can try compute
doing the computations.
So I hope I'm sure you will be
able to do that and otherwise we
can we can, we will be able to
do it either in a canvas or in
the class in the next class, OK.
OK, so so now we are talking
about more elements.
So before going there, we will
look at the probability
distribution.
So so when we have a data when
we have random data.
So we have, uh, a random
variable.
Often we make an assumption that
it follows a probability density
function as given here.
Which is called as a normal
distribution or a Gaussian
distribution.
So what are the properties of
normal distribution or the
Gaussian distribution that is
going to look like this?
So this is a very smooth and
symmetric and distribution.
So which is representing that?
What is the meaning of the value
here?
Suppose this is X.
So this is going to represent
the probability density at this
point of X and then the area of
the curve which is before the
green line says that.
What is the?
This is X1.
So what is the probability that
X is less than X1 is the area of
curve of green shade?
And then the complete area of
the curve, complete area full
area.
Under curve.
Can somebody guess what is the
full area under the curve?
One probably.
You did one one month.
Actually, according to the
employee to eat family, my dad
It is one.
It is a probability density
function.
The sum of the density for all
possible values is 1.
has never gonna rule on how much
candy and employee because he
mostly doesn't seem so straight.
And we really do.
Is somebody saying something?
Just let me come back.
OK, alright.
So this is what we often tend to
take and when we and the the
probability density function may
also be understood using these
curves.
So this is from the source from
Wikipedia.
So when mean is 0 so we can see
that depending on the variance.
Ohh, so the blue is showing that
a small variance, so the that is
how the cow look likes it.
It is going to have a
significant high density, high
value at the mean and when you
increase the Sigma squared to
one and five you can see that
the curve is getting flattened
out and when you change the mean
mean MU then then what is going
to happen when you change the
mean then the entire curve moves
to the right or left.
If you make it minus MU is minus
the entire cover moves to the
left, and when you make it
positive it moves entire curve
moves to the positive, so the
shape of the curve doesn't
So.
change, but it simply translates
to the right or left depending
on the change in May.
And then this is representing
the cumulative distribution
function.
So that tells that when you are
talking about what is the we
simply said that your compute
the area under the curve, but
then the area under the curve
can be plotted using the
function.
Because this is a mathematical
expression, somebody can do
integration and plot.
So this is what that plot looks
like and video often.
This is a.
This is a very good.
Symmetric distribution.
But very often we get end up
getting skewed distribution when
we have a long tail on the
positive side, we call it as a
positively skewed distribution.
We call this a positively skewed
distribution in a positively
skewed distribution.
The the way will be that mean is
greater than median is greater
than wood and the this is for
positively skewed and the exact
opposite for the negatively
skewed.
Negatively skewed, so we know
that the mean is less than
median.
Let's Dave mode.
So that tends to be the nature
of these cube distributions and
but then for the skewed
distribution, we do not have
such a simple mathematics like
the Gaussian distribution.
Mathematics are readily
available, but skewed
distribution.
We may have to do our own
approximations and then need to
fix it.
OK, so so the empirical relation
that is observed with the large
volumes of data that have a
skewed relationship is this is
not a, there is no mathematical
rigor to this, but then this is
what is observed with large
volumes and skewed
distributions.
And and now let us come to the
formula for standard deviation
and the standard deviation is
the.
So so now you can say the
standard deviation is Sigma or
yes and the variance is the
square of that.
And this is the formula when it
is a sample.
When it is a sample, you compute
using uh you using, you use the
symbol.
Yes, some authors use the symbol
yes for sample and symbol Sigma
for population.
So when it is when it is a
sample, you use yen minus one in
the denominator.
When it is population you use
capital in full population.
Uh, so does somebody want to
explain why that is happening?
Sample is a very limited set of
data, whereas population can be.
But tends to a very large
number.
But then why for the sample
instead of using the sample
size, you use the sample size
minus one?
It's like the series of all
Nature series of natural numbers
N into n -, 1 by.
No, no, no, no.
I no, I think no.
It may be missed the point that
I'm just checking if anyone of
Like.
you can give a some some answer
which stays with the sample.
Lately sample sample list sample
list.
We you have a small sample of 10
then you still want to say the
denominator is 9 rather than 10.
Sample is always less than the
actual data.
Absolutely, absolutely.
Mr KAVIN, I think sample range
will be always smaller than the
population range.
So.
So what we are doing is that by
reducing the denominator we are
trying to capture the variance
in the population from the
sample data.
By reducing because the sample
range is small, but so to get a
better estimation of the
population variance or standard
deviation, So what we do is that
when we do a sample, we know
that we are not capturing the
entire range.
So what we do is that we reduce
the denominator so that that
will give a better indication of
it.
It becomes a representation of
the population value.
So suppose that let me drop
pictorially.
So maybe you will understand.
So suppose that there is a data
in one dimensions one
dimensional space.
So the data range is from here
to here.
Suppose that you have taken some
random samples, random samples
on taking with a different
color.
OK, so the random samples are
here.
Here, here, here.
Now you know that using the
random samples.
So if you use the population
formula you are going to
represent the variance with this
range, but you want to capture
the variance with the for this
range.
So you are reducing the
denominator so that it becomes a
better estimate.
Are you saying the reducing the
denominator for adjusting for
possible sample bias?
No, no, there is nothing like
bias any the bias is even if the
bias is not there, still the
range will be less.
Is that correct?
In fact, if the range is same
for the sample and population
Yes, it's just saying.
when the sample size is much
smaller than, it means that the
So give it a straight.
sample has a bias.
If you say that you are getting
a full range with the sample,
possibly the sample has some
bias because you you are extra
careful and you are taking the
edge cases.
But if you take a random sample,
it should not capture the full
range.
Is that right, Mr Rajesh?
The random sample will not
capture the full range.
Yeah.
But why?
Once her why we are reducing by
only one?
What is the logic behind that?
OK.
OK, OK.
So.
So no, there is.
See you are trying to make an
estimate, so you can always say
that too, but then you can.
I think it is working now.
But two is not proper because
what we are saying is that
He has never made fun.
suppose that there is a range
that is a range from.
That you should be able to
download data then only you can
ohk. OK.
Huh.
OK, deceiving name with.
Mr Ananth Narayan, you want to
say something?
Sorry, sorry.
That was, I should be
understood.
OK, why n -?
One you think about it, that is
the best possible change that
you can do.
For example, suppose that you
got a data which is in the range
of zero to 1000.
That is, the entire population
range.
So when you take a population,
when you try to get the
population which is only 10% of
that, then you need to recognize
that the the what you miss is
likely to be about 10%.
So instead of using hundred, you
want to use 99.
So when you multiply, it becomes
990, so that is what you will
miss.
So you think about it, there is
nothing like I can give you an
answer.
So that is how all the
statistics books, right and most
of the statistics books will not
explain to you because that is
pretty much an intuition.
Who said that small N that you
are showing there it is the
sample size, not the whole size,
right?
8 sample size.
That is correct.
So out of 1000, if you're taking
ten as sample, then we will
divide it by 9.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, just one
minute.
Is what we are saying.
You have taken 10% of the
sample, 10% as the sample.
So then, what do you what you
are doing?
Is that suppose that you are you
are taking hundred but you are
taking 10% of the sample will
become hundred OK.
So instead of using 100, So what
you are doing is that you are
Mm-hmm.
reducing it to 99 because what
you think is that when you take
a sample of size 10%, the range
will also reduce by 10%.
If you take a sample of 100%,
the range will be 100%, but then
you take a sample of size 9010%.
If you take a temple, sorry.
Just one minute.
When you take a sample which is
1 by.
Sample size is 10%, so 1 by 10.
So it is there is a good
likelihood that you will miss
that much in the range and you
will compensate.
So.
So just let let us see 1000 from
990.
So so basically it's the IT is.
Yes, there is a simple.
So you are taking 99%, so
alright.
Yeah, OK.
Because what you do is that you
will adjust the the range 100,
so you will miss about one by
hundredth of that.
So you will miss about so 10%
you take.
So suppose that you have taken
100, so forget about 10% you
take 100 out of 1000, so you are
likely to miss the range by
about 1 by 100.
So that is the estimation.
So based on that you will see
that you have to use 99 as the
fraction so that will compensate
for what you missed as that 1%
missed no.
So.
So because what we are saying is
that we are missing the, we are
taking 100 as a sample.
So what we miss will be about 1
by 100 of the range.
So we are removing that one by
hundred from the denominator so
that we will get the proper
value.
So this is the intuition.
So.
So just go with that and.
OK.
A misunder ya.
Is your your explaining
something?
Standard deviation represents
the average distribution, not
the whole distribution.
I do not know is that.
Key.
No, right.
So we don't be.
So this is the formula so I hope
we are there.
Then we will look at skewness
and kurtosis in order to
understand the distributions.
So skewness and kurtosis is the
they are given by the formula.
So you can see that there is a
formula for skew and there is a
formula for kurtosis.
So what we are saying is that
when these are have the values,
so the books will give you what
is the acceptable range.
What is not acceptable?
So if we take the data and then
suppose that we are having the
data which is represented by the
histogram like this, you can see
that the difference between the
histogram on this sheet one and
histogram on sheet three you can
see that the skew and kurtosis
have changed right?
So so now that can give you a
indication that the they are
indications that how close you
are to the normal distribution.
So the skew we generally
computed using this formula you
are writing to the power of
three, so you may get positive
or negative values.
Positive values will be
representing skew in One
Direction and negative value in
the other direction.
Because when you raise it to the
power of three, you say that you
retain the sign when it is
raised to the power of two, you
lose the sign.
So the point is, negative skew
indicates that the data is
skewed to the left and long left
tail and positive skew indicates
that long positive tail.
And then when kurtosis is
representing that nature of the
so for example, you are looking
at the Gaussian distribution and
a high kurtosis is representing.
As you can see here, the high
kurtosis is represented by this
example and the negative
cortosis is represented by this
example.
So the kurtosis is something
which is telling that.
How is it the data is differing
from a normal distribution so so
this is giving you any
indication so you are better
prepared that how much error the
normal distribution may give to
me.
So this is not really saving you
saying that you have to invent a
new formula, but it can give you
and then if it is significantly
different then you start
exploring the other possible
mathematics.
And then we have for the
discrete sample data we consider
the quartiles.
We consider the quartiles so
quartile.
Is it 25th percentile?
So we consider Q12Q1Q2Q3.
So Q4 is representing the end of
the data.
So we put the data in a sorted
sequence and we find out what is
the 25th percentile.
What is the 50th percentile?
This is same as median 50th
percentile is same as median and
then you have you also find 75th
percentile.
So these are considered as
interesting quartiles by when
people analyze the data many
times.
So interquartile range is Q3
minus Q1.
What is the value at 75th
percentile and minus?
What is the value at 25th
percentile?
So many people like to describe
their data using 5 number
summary.
This is one of the popular ways
in which people describe the
data.
So suppose that you have got a
data like this.
So which is which is which you
mean get it in a random
sequence.
First you need to sort it into a
increase ascending sequence.
Then you start computing, so you
need to count.
There are five numbers here.
Uh for 10152022, so I think
about 32 values, right?
I'm assuming that so now you
need to compute accordingly the
quartile is.
This is 20th percentile, so 20th
percentile we are taking I think
24 numbers or 22 numbers.
So 20 is coming as the first
quartile, the median is coming
as 25th.
One of these then the queue
three 7550% is coming is like
this and then maximum is this so
that is one of the ways in which
we are going to capture and this
we have already discussed the
Esquire and Sigma Square.
So generally what is considered
is that we make a box plot of
the data and boxplot.
I think we have visualized in
the next slide.
So give any data we take the
lower extreme which is min
minimal, right, upper extreme
maximum.
Then this is 25th percentile.
Our Q1 and then this is the 75th
percentile.
Our Q3 and then this is the and
then median is 15th percentile.
So generally this is represented
by the box because that box is
supposed to capture the the
significant range for the
variable for which we are
getting the values because 25th
to 5070 fifth percentile should
give you an indication that that
is the most likely answer that
you get when you try with some
random thing for which you do
not know the major, it is likely
to fall in this range so that
but it we just give the
importance by drawing a box
around it.
And what we also do is that we
start we we use the whiskers to
lines outside the box extended
to minimum and maximum.
So what we generally do is that
the outliers are computed based
on IQR.
So what we do is that we say Q 1
-, 1.5 * I QR is unlikely to be
a data that is generated by
normal process.
So it is with this we can treat
as an outlier.
Similarly, when we see something
like Q 3 + 1.5 times IQR, we
think that that is unlikely to
be generated by normal process.
It is an outlet, so now let us
look at the example for this.
We have computed the min, Max,
Q1Q3, median.
So now the IQR.
What is the IQR?
What is the QR?
15 right.
Is that clear or somebody's
uncomfortable?
In.
Q3 minus Q1.
We can.
Yeah, somebody's comfortable,
right?
Everybody's comfortable.
Yeah.
Yes, Sir.
Alright, so now let us compute
1.5.
Times I QR.
This is equal to 22.5.
So now let us look at Q3.
It is 35 and Q1 it is 20.
So if it is 20 -, 22.5 it is
something less than this,
something less than this is less
than this.
Then we think that it is an
outlier.
Similarly, X is greater than 35
+ 22.5 then also we suspect that
it is an all clear.
So now when we seeing this 70 is
looking like you know, OK.
Does it look like an outlier
when you look at the data?
Think it's all?
I'm just trying to understand.
This.
Will you please explain me once
once again IQR I'm able to
understand what 1.5 from where
we are getting.
No.
We are getting from nowhere.
That is a general agreement
among all the people saying that
more than 1.5 IQR, I will treat
it as an outlier.
OK, not.
This is nothing so.
So, OK, one thing you may say
that OK, has it come out as a
vacuum?
What?
What is generally considered is
that when Barry, the normal
distribution people, have a
tendency to believe that when
new.
Minus 3 Sigma or MU plus three
Sigma, or likely to be outliers.
So that is what many people
consider.
And if the data same data that
you got for use it for box plot
you try to push it into a normal
distribution.
The approximate value you get
for the 1.5 IQR should be this
if assuming that the data is
strictly formal following normal
distribution, but then you we
that is not an exact equation
that is an approximation.
So.
So, since there is a 3 Sigma or
Six Sigma as the valid range for
normal distributions, so why not
use 1.5 IQR which is nearest
value that you can get as the as
the filtering mechanism with
boxplots?
Is that clear?
There is no.
If.
There is no rigorous
mathematics, but it is an
approximation to plus minus 3
Sigma.
Does this apply only to normal
distribution or also to gamma
No, no.
distribution?
See.
See, the point is that when you
have many other distributions,
obviously you cannot get them
right, right?
So the the I I'm just trying to
answer that 1.5 comes close to
OK.
three Sigma.
If it is normal distribution,
but then nobody will tell you
OK.
that it is 1.5 is they have
taken because they want to match
3 Sigma.
They simply say that take one
point.
Of course, if you if your data
or your own business, or if your
So.
own sense of the data says that
you need to use different levels
for like your, you can use it
because you think that for your
business you are selling some
product and you have a wide
range of characteristics of the
people.
So you are free.
I mean, there is nothing.
Nobody's imposing this.
But then outlier itself is an
interesting concept.
So what is an outlier is really
something which which is always
a always a something like we
don't have an exact answer.
What is it now?
Clear.
But then outliers are something
that all the businesses are weak
in on capturing.
So for example, I tell I think I
had.
So suppose that you are working
for a bank and you are
interested in getting the
customers.
So you set up an office in,
let's say, in one of the IT
district of one of the cities.
So you will get many people who
have got a income in the range
of, let us say 1 range, some
range X2Y and now add to the
same place.
Suppose that Mister Gautam Adani
walks in and says that I want to
open the account in the bank, so
the bank should make a special
note of that person.
Is it not so now if you ask me
why and what?
But then you assume right?
So that is what we that is, that
should be important for the
bank.
So that obviously because that
person is not matching any of
these numbers.
Makes sense?
So Venkat, suggest one
confirmation.
Right.
So here in the calculation that
is there, yeah.
Yes.
I will you please say yes.
So 1.5 multiplied by IQR is
nothing but third quartile.
You're referring to, which is
nothing but X +, -, 3 Sigma.
No, no, no, no.
Don't go into X + -, 3 Sigma,
because we are not capturing the
mean.
Here we are capturing the median
so.
So what I told you is that don't
go.
Don't rush into that.
But mean but but mean median.
OK.
OK, Mr Mr.
Please allow me to speak.
Mr Saurav.
Mr Saurav, just hold on that I
gave as an intuition to some
people, but most likely the data
science.
Many of the data science books
will not tell you that this this
is the reason why they say they
say that use 1.5 as a good
estimate for how clear and if
your business demands that 1.8
IQR is a better estimate based
on your own understanding of
data, please go.
And please allow me to speak.
Uh, Mr Oswaldo?
I I have not spoken, but you
allowed me.
You you just, you know, made me
shut down.
So please allow me to speak.
No.
Now you can speak now you can
speak because of because I
Yeah, please.
thought you wanted me to answer
the question about 3 Sigma which
I cannot answer because the
three Sigma does not apply
because this is a very rough
approximation.
Go ahead.
I do not know you.
You are here to learn, Mr
Saurab.
So so now the question is that
when you are trying to jump then
it has become difficult for me
to answer because The thing is
Hell, I speak.
that this.
Yes, please go ahead.
Go ahead.
What I am trying to ask you is X
+, -, 3, Sigma where mean in
normal distribution is mean,
median and mode is same right?
No, no, no.
That's what I was trying to ask
you.
No, no, no, no, no.
See, The thing is that if it is
a normal distribution, you may
get mean, median, mode clothes
same.
Yeah. Yes.
So because of that, you may say
that the median, but then very
He's.
often when we deal with the
small samples like this, we have
Umm.
already seen that we have taken
another sample of 20.
So we could not match the mean,
median and those, so they'll
Umm.
seldom match exactly.
So in that sense, so saying that
X plus we Sigma is what is
Hmm.
matching is not correct.
But then if suppose that somehow
ideal data we have got so ideal
Hmm.
data.
This comes as a rough
approximation.
Yeah.
Yes, yes, yes, so.
It is not a exact approximation,
a rough approximation.
Yeah, so here X is nothing but X
bar.
I am trying to say you.
Yes, yes, X bar.
So yeah.
You can take it as a mean
because the data is perfectly
Hmm.
Yes. Yes, yes.
symmetric, yes.
Yeah.
So that's what I'm I'm asking
you that normal distribution,
that's the reason I I turned the
I coined I I turned the word the
third three quartile.
Right.
So 1.5 multiplied by IQR is
nothing but three quartile.
Uh-huh.
That's what I was trying to say.
Uh, OK, OK.
Mr Saurav, just take it as an
intuition.
This is not a mathematical
formula saying that we are using
identical measures with normal
distribution and box plot, but
Got it. And.
then take that as it just as an
intuition, nothing more.
Yeah, yes, yeah.
So most of the data science
books will tell you that take
1.5 IQR above the median or
below the median because they
Yes, yes, yes.
don't want to risk.
You risk telling you that median
is same as me because in that
Yeah, got it.
case they think they are
misleading.
No problem.
Got it.
Alright.
All right, now we are seeing
that the basic statistical
distributions can come from
several visualizations.
So one of the visualizations is
the box plot.
And we can also make histograms
we have already seen an example
histogram and then we have
quantile plot.
So so this is an indication of
the value versus percentile.
So suppose that quantile plot is
an interesting kind of a plot.
Suppose that you got a data
which is of this kind which is
of this kind.
OK, so which is is 1 dimensional
distribution of something.
Maybe this is representing a
something like age of some group
of people in in a support in one
street that maybe that maybe so.
In that case, what is happening
is that you want to plot it
because you want to.
Visualization is going to give
you an indication of the
variation in the data, but with
one dimensional data there is no
visuals that are available, so
one visual that people use is
known as a quantile plot.
So quantile plot works like
this.
Suppose there is a data which is
for example.
I'm plotting the unit price
along One Direction and in other
direction.
What I'm doing is I'm plotting
the percentile value percentile
value can from zero to 1%.
1% is 100 percentile, .75 is 75
percentile.
Then this is the median.
This is the median and this is
the Q1 and then this is this is.
This is Q3, so you can make it
plot and now you know that this
is the place where where the
maximum and minimum are
constrained.
0 percentile in one percentile,
but then you may get the data
which can vary vary along.
This is this, this this so you
it can give you an indication
that when you get 2 datasets and
then you plot and you get a
different shapes for the
quantile plot that tells you
about the ordering that is
available within that data.
So you just need to think about
it because we have a one
dimensional data and we are
trying to do a visualization.
And the meanwhile, let us also
look at the other plots.
Other plots is.
Let's look at histogram and bar
graph.
So probably 11 input server
there, so probably 1 tile.
Yes, yes.
Can you go to the quantile for a
moment please?
Ohh you want me to look at a
show this slide of contact.
Yes, yes, yes, please.
OK, OK.
Yeah, this is the contact, yeah.
To probably one of the use case
could be how organizations to
the market correction of
employee salaries.
Are you are saying what can be
the use of this is it?
Is it correct?
Yeah, 11 practical scenario I
could think of is the market
correction, right?
Yeah.
So where?
Yeah.
No, no, I don't know whether
you're talking about stock
market, but what what we are
saying is that, yeah, OK, So
No.
OK, OK.
what, what do you see?
What the quantile plot is
telling you is that there is the
greater concentration of the
element, so that is what it is
trying to tell you, which are
the for example closer to the
median or closer to 30
percentile or closer to the
because the the plot is going to
take a higher incline there and
lower incline at another places.
So based on the incline of the
plot at various places, you get
an indication that is Daddy more
concentration at some place.
So suppose that.
Suppose that let me let me give
you a quantile plot quantile
plot.
Let us say this quantile plot
has got 80 as the median and
1:20 as the highest 40 as the
lowest.
So now let me make a alternate
quantile plot, which is in
extreme.
So now I'm saying that.
This I can have as a plot
because most of the elements are
closer to 40 closer to the 80
and so so many of more elements
are closer to 80 than to 40, and
similarly I can have something
like this.
Something like like this again
indicating that there are very
few elements which are closer to
100% so it is more of an
indication of the way it is
changing.
Just think about it, because I I
cannot explain these graphs.
So you people need to have your
own bring in some inclusion and
And then they have.
try to see that, but then this
is a quantile plot is a good
indication you you take the your
own some data and then plot it.
Then you will appreciate it
better rather than looking for
my English and then saying that,
OK, this word, that word know
that alright.
OK, OK.
Uh, Mr Raghavendra is saying,
what is this?
This is about the previous year
Question Paper.
See.
Don't rush for the question
papers, so I hope if you learn
the subject are you are you
really studying only for the
grades?
We will give you some sample
question but some time with no
warranty, no guarantee will give
you some sample, but I hope
you're not in here for grades.
The grades will come
automatically.
Somebody will get some grade.
Somebody will get other grade
and in any case, even if I give
you all the question papers and
guidebooks again, I have to give
you a variation of that grade.
But then focus on learning, so
we will give you some
indication, but then the the, I
the obviously there will be
changes that keep happening
between various faculties and
various topics in the the
Question Paper.
Alright, so now we have got.
Let's talk about histogram and
bargraph.
I hope the the difference is
clear.
Bargraph is talking about a
categorical variable versus the
numbers.
Histogram is a range versus
numbers, so that is how we use
the nomenclature and then
histogram has the ability even
when histogram is at least.
Of course it needs to have
sufficient number of intervals,
but the histograms can tell you
more than the box plot.
If you look at these two
datasets, they they have the
same five point summary, but
then the histogram is giving you
a different shape.
Alright.
And the quantile plot we
discussed, and it is also
possible that similar to
quantile plot, we can make a
quantile to quantile plot.
So what we are saying is that
here we are looking at the
example is taken from the T4 I
believe.
So suppose that there are two
branches of the same store.
For example, there is a same
retail chain that has got two
stores at two different places
and then they are stocking
different same items.
Let's say at both the places,
but then in some store installed
one the attending to sell more
high priced item and in Store 2
they're trending to high sell
more low priced item.
In that case, the the quantile
to quantile plot will be able to
capture that.
So you're looking at the branch
1 percentile and branch 2
percentile.
So what you are doing is you are
doing is branch one.
Suppose that the you are
plotting you are plotting like
this.
Suppose that for branch one.
So let me let me write that how
do you plot branch one?
Uh.
The then percentile percentile.
OK, this is one we want to
capture.
So now let us say 10 percentile,
20 percentile, 30 percentile and
all can be captured.
Then Branch one branch two.
So now what we are saying is 10
percentile for branch one is.
Let us say is 50 and branch two
is 51.
So we are going to make a plot
50 versus 51, OK.
And then 20 percentile.
So this is 55 and then 54.
So we are making a plot of this
point, and then we are
connecting all these points and
that is going to indicate that
in one branch there is a
different trend of the sale of
the product based on the price
compared to the other branch.
And the scatter plot is much
easier one.
I hope we frequently use it.
We commonly use when there are
two variables.
We simply make if scatter plot
and scatterplot is is what is.
What is the scatter plot telling
does?
Does anyone want to make a
reading of the scatter plot and
want to say something?
Feel free if you if you feel
like I'll wait for a few.
You do some correlation between
the two variables like how are
they related?
OK, it is telling you the
correlation.
Do you see any correlation in
the scatter plot that you have
seen?
Combining what I said this,
could you please show the OK so
and respected?
Median translations.
OK, first first when checking
those is blot, it's the the data
which they are choking off for.
Uh, what's the actual price and
how much it is?
Show that's.
Yes.
That's the first thing and in
which perspective which the same
items are different item doesn't
stock.
The items which we are so which
is buy from different, it can be
from different areas and
different styles because there
was no any information on that.
What we can summarize in this
plot is space and how much it
OK.
OK, fine, fine.
sold.
That's it.
So the minimum value for the
items is 40 and maximum is still
Fine, Mr.
120 and maximum items bought are
in the range somewhere around
80.
If we go back to the graph 8200.
OK.
No, I'm.
I'm actually looking for.
OK.
OK, fine, fine.
Just just let me put it this
way.
I am looking more for whether
have you noticed some pattern
which is a very approximate
pattern that the reason?
There's no Yep.
So if the item is too cheap,
then it would not be sold, and
And what close to the normal
because it represents Bell.
Yeah.
And and then you you can see
some patterns, right?
if it is too costly, it would
not be sold too.
It's somewhat most of the normal
thing.
Curves.
But.
Yeah.
So he did a very, very rough
pattern, but then you you have
That.
got some indication.
So in fact, our course is all
about finding whether there is
What with?
we can catch the pattern.
Normal distribution.
No, no, it is not normal
distribution.
And what close to the norm?
What we are saying is that there
is a tendency of people to buy
middle level price products and
ads come to you as you come to
the lower price product.
There is a very few buyers or
something like that items sold.
I am assuming the number of
buyers and similarly when it is
coming to the higher price
product and there are very few
buyers is that are you seeing
the same pattern that I'm
seeing?
Yeah, that makes sense.
OK, alright, alright.
So.
So now what we are saying is
that these graphs can tell you
several things.
So so for example, we are seeing
various types of correlations,
so this is a positive
correlation.
So when we are saying that as X
is increasing, Y is also
increased and this is a negative
correlation.
So as X increases, Y has a
tendency to decrease, reduce,
correct?
So adds let me put it this way,
Ajax increases.
So why is it tending to regules
and this here as X increases, Y
increases up to set endpoint and
beyond that point there is a
negative correlation.
So you may start looking for
certain patterns and there can
be.
Sometimes you can work with end
up getting a data which is
totally uncorrelated.
As you can see here.
OK, so this is all I wanted to
cover.
So I'm now open to questions.
So can you take me a slide #19?
Slight number 19, is that
correct?
Right, right.
Correct. Correct.
OK.
Slide #19, I am I here in this
one?
Right here.
So yeah.
Correct, correct. Right.
Yeah.
Correct.
OK.
OK, good.
Good. Yeah.
So so this is 35 + 22.5.
That is, you know, 57.5 this is
1 whiskers you talked about,
right?
Yes.
I missed that Trump.
So we are saying that the 70 is
and how clear, right?
To here as per this calculation.
So 57.5 is 1 whisker points,
another is minus 2.5.
Am I correct?
No, but there is no minus 2.5.
So we say that there is no
outlier on lower side, but there
is an outlier on higher side.
So you use the term whiskers
right?
What exactly that Tom says.
Can can you be little louder?
Your voice is coming very low to
me.
Right.
Yeah, you you said that whiskers
right in one point of time, I I
Uh, OK, OK.
I.
OK, whiskers are something that
you put in the.
So the viscous actually people
put at two places.
So one is suppose that there is
a.
There is a minimum and maximum
of the data.
Then what you say is that the
acceptable maximum and
acceptable minimum is one thing
where they plot the whiskers and
then the this is this is the way
they put.
OK, so that there may be some
data here in some data may be
outside.
So, so the OK, so now.
OK, fine.
The whiskers the it's talking
about is these lines.
OK.
The the slide is talking about
this, but sometimes people also
put the lines here.
So OK, so there are two things.
So what the slide is saying is
these two lines, but people also
put the lines here.
Am I have you confused you or is
it clear?
No.
Is there any relationship we
have with course with that IQ or
that's what I'm trying to
understand?
Dave Whiskers are no, no, no,
no.
Biscuits are just indicating the
lines that the the convention of
plotting the five five point
summary or box plot.
OK, OK.
So you take the, you put the box
from Q1 to Q3, but outside that
you only have the lines and the
horizontal lines are the range
and the vertical lines or the OR
the minimum and maximums.
So this is representing the
minimum and maximum and this is
OK.
Thank you.
representing that there are
values along.
See, these are all conventions,
no.
So nothing like nothing really
to explain.
So this is the shape of what
they do.
Are we In Sync, Mr?
So do we need to remember these
all different types of plotting
Yeah.
Thank you.
and that data analysis are?
No, no, this five point somebody
so close.
You, you, you are going to use
it so frequently when you do the
data analysis.
So yeah, you may.
Yeah, this I think we'll, I I do
not think anybody had a
challenge and remembering this.
So this is this is the way the
any book you look at the five
point summary.
This is how they travel.
Any other question that anyone
has?
Uh, so any data visualization
tool you would recommend us to
put our hands on?
I think we see the data
visualization even in Python.
You can do it using the Mac Plot
library.
Uh, but you can use certainly
use the the tools that are
available outside Python also,
but I nothing like the
visualization of what we cover
is really simple things.
So.
So which you can always actually
with the Mac Plot library.
Got it.
So just trying to understand in
this entire course so far
introduction to data science,
will we also be preparing and
preparing the dashboards or
presenting graphical present?
Not the dashboards. No.
No.
See the dashboard meaning is
certainly represents a business
is having some critical
parameters and you want to do
that.
No, it is unlikely that we will
go into because our focus is
more on finding the patterns.
So you will call dashboard when
you have got 10 critical
parameters that you want to
show.
So I do not think we will.
OK, fear of maybe my question
was wrong, but yeah, considering
We will create a dashboard.
will link the patron patron
identification.
Young at the pattern that you
that you will show in a
So we'll be doing.
graphical way.
Why not?
Yeah, yeah, that you can always
show it in a graphical way.
Hmm.
OK.
So for example, you are making a
linear regression, so why not?
OK, everybody practice tools.
Hmm.
Why can't you show it in link?
Yeah.
Will we be practicing to say
along with you in this course?
Uh, see, I think see we will not
have enough enough time to cover
Python extensively.
Python is a common language for
all your courses, and all of us
will be giving you a little bit
NILAN on Python, but you need to
explore it on your own because
we have some webinars where we
can give you some exposure, but
you need to explore because
there is so many libraries and
so much of publicly available
documentation.
So we will not be able to cover
Python in a few hours, so you
you have to explore and and we
will expect that you develop
some level of proficiency so
that you can do solve and
assignment.
You can do the assignment.
We will give you the background,
so some level of exposure we can
give you, but then you need to,
but I just want to four, one
that you have to do significant
exploration yourself.
The definitely, Sir, definitely.
Just an heads up would be
enough, Sir.
Like we need to do what?
Yeah.
We we will give you some, some
we will hopefully we will have
take some either Colab notebook
or something just show how to
play with it.
But there there is a lot of
publicly available
Perfect. Yeah.
documentation.
The language documentation.
It's a language manually ONLINE
language language so so you need
to be willing to look at it.
Sure.
So it's already given as a part
of audit Course 4 sessions we
had with pythons which span
across basics of Python how to
do data visualizations and all
other stuff the.
OK. Very good.
Yeah, very good. Yeah.
Yeah, right.
OK.
If there are no more questions,
we'll close the session.
All right.
Thank you.
So thank you.
Yeah, sure.
Thank you, Sir.
Thank you.
I think we'll get some.